what do you got daniel jones this is a
year he's got to develop
show me something daniel jones at some
point
the quarterback has to lift his team
show me something daniel jones this is
the kind of game that daniel jones has
to get right
show me something daniel jones at home
big game
philadelphia eagles this is a game
daniel jones that you were drafted to
win show me something
and daniel jones did show us all
something last week with the win over
the philadelphia eagles peter i have a
prediction i predict you will not be
selecting daniel jones this week because
the giants are on a buy although you can
pick him if you would like to he could
show you what he's doing on his bye week
but i have a feeling that uh that that
will not be one of your selections but i
that's uh hey who knows where daniel
jones is going to go peter i've i've
been impressed i've been concerned but
right now it looks like he could be
moving in the right direction we are
going to move through the show me
something draft i have a trivia question
for you
speaking of the giants you mentioned
super bowl 25 earlier
who was the holder
for the ill-fated 47-yard field goal by
scott norwood that went wide right
frank wright
all right is that right
that's right i don't know the horns is
that right there are the horns that's
right you get the first pick well done
right good good
okay but didn't even didn't even
hesitate didn't even have to think about
it i like it you get the first pick well
there was a reason you were going to ask
me if it was joe schlobotnick you would
not have asked that question
i didn't know who it was and i for all i
knew it was josh
he's a good friend of mine and i do
remember i do remember after the game
standing in the media food line at about
12 30 in the morning behind morton
anderson who had done the game on danish
tv
and we were just talking and i said
what'd you think and he goes
you know i don't think the laces were in
the correct position aerodynamically and
i'm paraphrasing this was 30 years ago
but he said i think that the late the
the position of the laces helped the
ball
you know go to the right from scott
norwood and you know for whatever that's
worth i don't know
all right you get the first selection
this week show me something not daniel
jones
show me something
drew locke who's going to become my new
daniel jones
ten interceptions the last five weeks
ten interceptions the last five weeks
and
you know i think that in the off season
there was this sort of uh narrative
around denver hey we got everybody
we got jeff judy we are jerry judy we've
got uh kj hamler uh we've got we've got
all of these new weapons we brought in
melvin gordon we
we are in great position now
to have our long-term offensive weaponry
in place and okay all right drew lock
you're the guy let's go
but there's one thing about this
drew lock was always sort of
the guy who until he proved otherwise
was a little bit along for the ride and
so far he's shown that he's along for
the ride
and that john elway had better be
studying the quarterbacks in this draft
because look
it's not logical to think that drew lock
is going to play great against this this
hyper defense that uh this hyper
aggressive defense that miami has
but he's got to start playing great
against somebody
so let's say this sunday
show me something drew locke that you
belong as the long-term quarterback of
the denver broncos
yeah between the ineffectiveness and the
injuries that's the key he's had too
many injuries if you want to be your
franchise quarterback you have to be
available to the franchise the best
quarterbacks just don't miss games show
me something
jameis
winston assuming that we will see him
possibly as the starter if not as the
starter as a guy who plays plenty on
sunday for the saints against the
falcons the last team winston faced as a
member of the tampa bay buccaneers
throwing that interception in overtime
that ended the season and his career in
tampa this is his opportunity this is
his teddy bridgewater moment potentially
to come in and reestablish himself in
the nfl and maybe get teams to start
thinking about jameis winston as a
potential starter when it's time to spin
the wheel of free agency in march of
2021 peter so show me something jameis
winston
show me something matt eberflus
speaking of uh the
you know spinning the wheel of free
agency how about spinning the wheel of
guys who are going to get interviewed to
be head coaches after this season
this is precisely the kind of game that
is going to draw interest to matt
eberflus as a head coach in the nfl in
2021 the first time in his career that
he's had a chance to game plan
for aaron rodgers
and so this is going to be one of those
days that you say okay
i like the colts defense as i said
earlier they've held
six of nine foes under 300 yards but
those six of nine foes have not been
quarterbacked by aaron rodgers show me
something matt eberflus
show me something ezekiel elliott we
mentioned him earlier in the program the
disappointing performance so far this
year two weeks to get ready the vikings
defense a bunch of guys who weren't
supposed to be playing defensive line
are playing defensive line i see guys
out there with numbers i recognize names
i don't this is ezekiel elliott's
opportunity to reestablish himself the
passing game needs
a real running game threat in order to
get those guys on the outside going now
that andy dalton is back if the cowboys
are going to turn it around and try to
double their win total between sunday
and thursday against the vikings and
then washington zeke has got to be a big
part of it show me something ezekiel
show me something carson wentz i mean
he's he could be my new daniel jones too
because
you know he no matter how many times
he gets uh
inordinate praise from the eagles from
his teammates from his coach whatever
the eyes do not lie
he's playing lousy now it doesn't help
that he's got a poor offensive line in
front of him
but it's so interesting that we're all
kind of looking at philadelphia at
cleveland as sort of a cleveland's gonna
win that game
i mean
that cannot be accepted
if you were doug peterson and carson
wentz
show me something not just today but in
the last seven weeks of this season
carson wentz
show me something
adam
gase this is your last best opportunity
to avoid joining a very small fraternity
of coaches who have gone 0 and 16. rod
marinelli hugh jackson they're saving a
seat for you adam and when you look at
the back end of the schedule this really
is the optimum chance to avoid that fate
extra time to get ready the chargers are
gonna find a way to do chargers things
and they're gonna let you hang around
you can steal this game play like you
did last monday night against the
patriots and the jets will make it to
one and nine
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports